excuse moi pas de problème jeune homme
vous suivez mon deuxième coup rossi
ouais non c'est non c'est la première
fois que je te vois comme ça n'allait
pas comme les autres tu peux pas
comprendre
on a tous un lien à quelque chose
d'incroyable il est il ya moindre chose
que je puisse faire pour vous pourriez
me tenir la main vous ne perdez pas de
temps vous
intéressant céline mcqueen qui bouge qui
perd bien encore je me sens déjà très
proche de toi je plus grand soin ses
paroles
tu es sûr que tu sauras girons je crois
que je serai gérer si je veux que ça
brice robin
tous à peu près 2% de la population à ce
genre de soucis compte tenu de vos
antécédents médicaux
nous ne sommes pas optimistes ce qui ne
va pas pour toi je te demande de te
battre pour
qu'est ce que tu vas faire avec ta
nouvelle liberté je préfère vivre le
moment présent avec toi je crois au fait
que le lien est partout vers la
gentillesse d'un inconnu dans l'amour de
votre famille
[Musique]
au fait que chacun d'entre nous à un but
même si on ne le voit pas